it's difficult you know it's difficult
to tell where he is with his mind need
to get respect and hurt Emily no listen
I'm bigger I'm stronger than you and I'm
gonna hell it and the same thing just
yesterday i'm delia where this is the
fire
[Music]
I'll just keep on an amazing view from
the fire - keep an eye on it because
that minute is the top man so you have
to watch he's above you and video
tracing so I watch it 1 iron potentially
I could fight next year but has a long
time lots of things campaign between
anomalies focus you know I wake up early
every morning because I can't sleep I
just want to just go and do I need to do
trainer push my boxing career forward I
believe his biggest weapon against this
fight is gonna be his jab and his
replica you've been burned a lot lately
when he fights short fighters which is a
good weapon there will be cautious
challenger he needs to go out there and
put the hurt and him early and I believe
if he does that do we have a lot of
success than if he gets defensive and
whoever came is also first today me as
always spin freedom Illinois and he's
been there if you don't been knocked
down a few times so he needs to sort of
find a way of reassuring that in his
mind that listen I'm not here to play
I'm younger I'm big and I'm stronger and
I'm the champion except I need to you
know show you that it's my turn some
partners come up for the third round
very cagey first open wrong gesture just
seems a bit tentative he's not being as
aggressive and as forceful as he usually
is in these fights when he gets hurt
it's always not kind of punch you know
Vladimir kind of punished me kind of
punched Park has been a very very good
job just taking enough space away and
faintly enough and movie enough to cause
a problem if you get him thinking I
going back he doesn't like it because
you're your neighbor Fighters backyard
you're not gonna win a decision you know
I'm a Jesus goal and winner will be
sitting he's knock him out physically
beat him down but Joshua is actually
China push the pace now and then what a
champion does try and close or fire off
strong that's the difference in this
fight
right now I love just for predicting
fight justice key the richer believe is
the jab under a poker and aspect the
obviously needs to use his feet and his
jump to keep him picking up a saw
I'm my whole thing is trying to get an
insert something to slip to make it
insect because if he throws one single
jab so frosting is a packing slip I'm
inside jab and to the sails back if
we're and Nike does we come in and
comment boom
that's the little justice kid I believe
the victory public he brings a lot
experienced at his file and he carries a
bit punch powers or one of justice
biggest weaknesses he doesn't say the
left foot come in a lot if you're a good
left hook
you can cause smell our problems and
Povetkin does have a good left hook
that's one of his main weapons that he
lacks the fro if you can't get him to
make mistakes early it will catch him
with a left hook he's just look for that
window and it would be d at some point
gesture does drop his right hand and he
doesn't see the left or coming every
fires got something they do and that is
one of the things he does so if I can
get him doing that any sense very good
chance of winning back here but this is
the beginning of the fifth round you
know he presses spin down let's go up on
his boxing very well his Chinese written
against Barrett King Barrett can stuck
in and diving and bobbing and weaving
watching his back he's quite sturdy
because you know what it David to win so
bad no I was actually did come and
actually got up and left the commentary
sent ago and called perfect you know
because you know I wanted to fight him
it's difficult you know it's difficult
to tell where he is with his mind need
to get respect and is hurt even let him
know listen I'm bigger I'm stronger than
you and I'm gonna hell and the same
thing just renewed a
now the victory is the victory I'm gonna
be perfect in he's gonna be just short
so the fight stop I've got a jumper so
he's taller than me but I've got a
chopper so only three jabs I chat with
him I'll check with him
I'll chat with him and that's all get in
so I'm coming inside I'm jumping as well
so we jump in I being slip slip
therefore I'll get inside therefore have
it king's key to victory is head
movement and kind of punch always if I
hits moving I'm not getting hit I'm here
Romina Romina movement moving and I can
hit I can attack either short fire I was
a perfectly nice to be aggressive take
the range away make it messy and just
really needs to fight him on the outside
I think Joshua is gonna win in the first
six rounds you know I think he you will
not give it you know Americans a good
fire like this various guys and their
two Olympic gold medalist I just believe
Joshua's youth and energy will prevail
and then you know unless he's made
mistakes and neglect things in camp I
can't see that they can be
[Music]